[Applaudissements]
ici dans cette salle
environ une personne sur trois ne
trouvais absolument aucun sens à sa vie
une personne sur trois c'est beaucoup de
monde c'est soit vous soit votre voisin
de gauche soit votre voisin de droite
c'est peut-être le voisin droite
ce chiffre peut vous paraître
extravagant mais sans doute assez proche
de la réalité en tout cas c'est ce que
nous suggère une étude
faite par deux chercheurs américains à
l'université de l'illinois à l'autre à
l'université de virginie qui ont eu la
bonne idée de collecter des données sur
le sentiment de sens dans la vie les
données internationales et de les
connecter au niveau de développement
économique c'est à dire le classique pib
est exprimé par habitant est ce qu'ils
ont observé est assez étonnant tout cas
c'est assez intriguant pour un
économiste du bonheur comme moi un
économie un économiste du bonheur si
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est c'est un
économiste qui regarde comment les
situations économiques des gens sont
connectés avec leur niveau de bonheur et
aussi comment leurs décisions sont
connectés avec leur niveau de bonheur
est ce que trouve un économiste du
bonheur lambda c'est toujours que plus
les pays sont riches plus les gens sont
satisfaits de leur vie ça c'est vraiment
le b à ba et pour le sens ça ne marche
pas du tout ce qu'on observait les les
chercheurs c'est que au contraire pour
le sens plus les pays était riche - la
proportion de gens qui trouvaient un
sens à leur vie était élevé donc
regarder cette relation une belle
relation linéaire négative avec une
pente négative et la france fait partie
des pays où la proportion de gens qui
trouvent un sens à leur vie la plus
faible autour de un sur trois comme je
voulais dit qu'ils ne trouvent pas de
sens à sa vie alors comment expliquer ce
paradoxe comment expliquer que dans les
pays riches où vous avez plus de droits
plus de liberté et plus d'argent vous ne
trouvez on le trouve moins fréquemment
du sens dans nos vies alors il ya
plusieurs explications à qui peuvent
expliquer ça qui peuvent donner et
donner un sens à sa justement je vais
m'attarder sur une seule d'entre elles
c'est l'individualisme et la montée de
l'individualisme
alors l'individualisme c'est quoi déjà
l'individualisme c'est pas l'égoïsme
l'individualisme c'est une façon de voir
le monde une fois sans devoir la vie qui
place l'individu au centre de tout
être individualistes ou avoir des
valeurs individualistes c'est penser que
la société fait d'individus qui prennent
des décisions individuellement dans le
but d'atteindre leurs objectifs
individuels qui très souvent tourner
autour du bonheur individuel ou de
l'épanouissement individuel
jusque là aucun problème
et puis le l'individualisme c'est ce qui
s'oppose en fait au collectivisme le
collectivisme c'est penser que les
décisions doivent être prises par des
groupes dans avec un objectif de
favoriser non pas le bien-être des
individus mais le bien-être collectif
alors pourquoi l'individualisme serait
un problème pour trouver du sens dans sa
vie ça fait pas évident comme ça mais en
fait si ça l'est parce que ça vient
rogner les différentes dimensions du
sentiment de sens dans la vie en fait
les chercheurs qui s'intéressent aux
sentiments de sens dans la vie on
repérait qu'il y avait trois grandes
dimensions dans ce concept de sentiments
de sens dans la vie le premier c'est la
cohérence l'idée que vous faites vous
êtes aligné entre vos valeurs et vos
actes et vous êtes aussi aligné avec
votre environnement le deuxième c'est là
ni signifiance avoir l'impression que
votre vie sert à quelque chose elle est
signifiante à vos yeux puis allez
signifiant de manière absolue à l'epa
futila n'est pas dérisoire et puis le
troisième c'est la finalité c'est avoir
une vie qui est inscrite dans une
direction très claire qui a un cap très
clair et l'ensemble fait ce sentiment de
sens dans la vie mais en fait être
individualiste ça vient rognés et vivent
dans une société individualiste
ça vient renier ses trois dimensions du
sens non seulement vous allez être prix
vous aller voir assez naturellement dans
des projets individuels qui sont
pertinents pour vous mais qui ne sont
pas forcément aligné avec les les
objectifs individuels des autres on peut
y avoir une sensation de nom cohérence
même de dissonances ce qui est important
pour vous à vos yeux tous ces petits
projets personnels dans lesquels vous
vous laissez aller enfin dans lesquelles
vous plonger ils sont importants pour
vous ils sont peut-être pas important
pour votre voisin donc quand vous allez
lui en parler il va peut-être regarder
ça de haut et les trouver le trouvais
trouvé ça tout simplement absurde ou
juste insignifiant dérisoire et puis
dans une société individualiste
c'est la responsabilité trouver du sens
allait donner à l'individu il n'y a pas
un sens clé en main qui nous seraient
donnés par la société
contrairement aux sociétés
traditionnelles plus collectiviste ou le
sens assez classiquement de suivre les
pas de la religion et d'oeuvrer pour le
bien de la communauté dans une société
individualiste il n'y a pas ce sens clé
en main chacun trouvé son sens donc on
voit déjà que dans une société individus
sont à des problèmes de de tous les
côtés pour trouver du sens donc c'est
pas étonnant que dans des sociétés
individualistes
développer économiquement on trouve un
peu moins de sens qu ailleurs
alors les sources de sens dans les
sociétés individualistes développer
c'est quoi on en a plein d'études
là-dessus et il est assez clair que et
ça fait sens encore une fois c'est que
ce sont ça tourne autour de projets
individuels dans les sociétés
individualistes le sens vient de projets
individuels ok lesquels c'est assez
classique 1 c'est la famille essaie
d'aider des projets qui tourne autour de
la carrière donc c'est la vie
professionnelle ok dans les sociétés
individualistes les sources
traditionnelles de sens que sont la
religion ou le travail pour la société
la communauté sont très secondaire et
arrive vraiment dans les dents les
aidant les réponses là vous avez en fait
je vous je ne voulais pas dit mais ça
c'est le résultat d'une recherche sur
les sources de sens déclaré par les gens
dans 17 pays développés dont la france
et le classement des sources de sens à
peu près le même partout et vous voyez
que dans ce classement la religion est
tout en bas et puis le travail pour la
société et et à une position
intermédiaire mais très très loin du
sommet le sommet ce sont des projets
individuels bon bah pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas on s'est détourné de
certaines sources de sens pour aller en
favorisant d'autres pourquoi pas sauf
que la première source de sens comme
vous le voyez c'est la famille mais
quand on est individualiste on a des
problèmes pour fonder une famille en
fait être individualiste c'est ce se
sont regardés un peu le nombre et c'est
trés égocentré s'est essayé de suivre
ses besoins de suivre ses envies et ses
pas c'est pas forcément de faire des
compromis qui vous permet de vous lier
aux autres et donc à terme fonder une
famille ou juste être en couple et
devient une sorte de challenge et c'est
ce qui pourrait expliquer que dans les
pays développés
dans tous les pays développés on observe
une tendance très forte depuis la
génération qui est née au sortir de la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est une montée
progressive contenu de du nom de la
proportion de célibataire et surtout de
la proportion de 100 enfants regardez ce
graphe vous voyez cette remontée très
forte du nombre de personnes sans enfant
depuis la génération née au sortir de la
seconde guerre mondiale dans tous les
pays développés on a entre 50% et 100%
de plus de personnes qui finiront leur
vie sans enfant et la plupart du temps
il voulait des enfants mais ils n'ont
pas réussi à les faire en fait
et on pense que si la tendance continue
parce que là on a les chiffres que pour
les personnes qui ont fini leur vie
reproductive donc disons les personnes
qui sont nées dans les années 70 mais on
n'a pas encore les chiffres définitifs
pour les plus jeunes générations c'est
normal et on va voir on va voir ce qui
va se passer pour les jeunes générations
mais a priori la tendance devrait
continuer on devrait ce sont les
prédictions arrivée sur des niveaux de
25 à 30% de la société qui finiront sans
enfant donc là vous avez graphique pour
les femmes et c'est le même pour les
hommes et c'est même pire pour les
hommes en fait c'est 2 à 3 % de plus
pour les hommes donc c'est une piste
pour trouver du sens c'est même la
première piste celle qui est la plus
privilégiée par les gens sauf qu'elle
est rendue difficile par les valeurs
individualistes
canton donc on voyait bien le problème
le problème c'est que l'individualisme
éloigne de certaines voies
traditionnelles vers le sens la religion
le travail pour la communauté et nous
invite à aller vers d'autres pistes mais
aussi à cause des valeurs
individualistes on a du mal à à à aller
sur ces chemins là on a du mal à faire
ce qu'il faut pour réussir dans ces
chemins là mais même pire encore que ça
quand on est individualiste quand on va
être en crise de sens c'est à dire quand
on va vivre un moment où le sens est
perdu on avait du sens mais on ne le
trouve plus classiquement quand on est
dans la crise de la quarantaine par
exemple
quand on est en crise de la quarantaine
ou à d'autres moments de la vie on va
essayer de retrouver du sens par des des
projets individuels qui vont pêcher de
la même manière c'est à dire des projets
individuels qui en termes de signifiance
et de cohérence seront pas bons en
termes de cohérence ce seront des
projets qui vous vous qui créeront
peut-être des frictions avec les autres
personnes et en termes de signifiant ça
n'aura d'importance qu'à vos propres
yeux donc cas classique en crise de la
quarantaine quels sont ses projets un
peu stéréotypé pour sortir de la crise
de sens je pense que ça vous parlera si
ce n'est pas vous ce sera à votre voisin
de droite
j'en vois trois le premier s'est quitté
son boulot de salariés est monté sa
boîte donc tout le monde veut devenir
auto-entrepreneur hockey deuxième voie
classique s'est quitté son boulot encore
et changer complètement le secteur
typiquement vous êtes banque et vous le
vous voulez devenir potier ou vous êtes
expert comptable et vous voulez devenir
boulanger bon pourquoi pas enfin si vous
pensiez que c'était original ça n'est
pas et puis petit roi encore peut-être
un peu plus original et encore c'est
d'amorcer une nouvelle phase de votre
vie par la douleur oui par la douleur
donc c'est pas aller dans un club sm pas
du tout c'est vous lancer dans un
marathon
ou dans un triathlon ou essayez de vous
entraîner pour des modes days c'est quoi
des meutes days des modèles ce sont des
parcours du combattant dans la boue d'où
le nom mendez
ou vous risquez des chocs électriques
parce que vous devez ramper sous des
fils barbelés électrifiés du double
c'est parfois dû 400 vols parfois du 600
volts
mais l'idée c'est quoi l'idée derrière
c'est d'avoir un rituel de passage qui
vous fait passer de votre vie d'avant à
votre vie d'après pour en finir avec
cette crise de sens et si vous avez
justement subi des décharges électriques
c'est encore mieux parce que vous avez
des stigmates du rituel de passage vous
savez que vous êtes passé par là
mais à la fin regardez reprenait cette
grille de lecture la cohérence la
signifiance la finalité mais vous allez
encore pêché en passant par ces canaux
là vous allez vous rendre compte que
finalement tout ça est important pour
vous mais c'est pas important pour les
autres en fait que vous et que vous ayez
fini un marathon en 3 heures 30 où 3h44
tout le monde s'en fout non mais
vraiment tout le monde s'en fout
et pire la société peut même être
perdante à vous voir tenter vos petites
aventures individuelles imaginez que
vous étiez salariés dans une grande
boîte en tant qu'économiste je vois très
bien la perte de productivité à voir
tous ces gens qui sont salariés dans des
grandes boîtes et qui atterrissent micro
entre auto entrepreneurs 2 même manière
si vous étiez un très bon banquet qu'à
20 ans d'expérience qui a fait hec qui
qui qui a fait de la formation continue
qui a accumulé énormément d'expérience
et de qualifications vous arrêtez tout
pour devenir pompier mais c'est un très
bon banquier qui devient un mauvais
potier
en termes économiques c'est une
catastrophe pour la société donc faut
bien comprendre que
ce qui peut faire sens à vos yeux peut
ne pas faire sens du tout aux yeux de la
société
donc qu'est-ce qu'elles sont les voies
en fait quels sont les voix si si si les
voies classiques individuelle ne
fonctionne pas parce qu elle pèche en
termes de cohérence elle pèche en termes
de signifiance mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire donc là sur la base de ce qu'on
s'est dit je vois deux voies possibles
l'une étant plus agréable que l'autre la
première c'est de partir tout de suite
sans même attendre le cocktail est
d'aller faire des enfants
ça c'est la partie agréable
la deuxième c'est cette se lancer dans
des projets certes librement choisi
individuellement choisi qui résonne en
vous qui sont signifiants pour vous mais
qui résonne aussi aux yeux de la société
en fait c'est de se lier dans de se lier
aux autres dans des entreprises
collectives dans le but de transformer
la société et donc d'atteindre un
objectif qui serait valorisée par vous
mais aussi par la société donc ça il ya
plein de façons de le faire c'est le
bénévolat on sait que les bénévoles
trouve plus de sens dans leur vie c'est
le fait de pourquoi pas de de quitter
votre job mais de quitter votre job pour
aller bosser après dans une entreprise
sociale solidaire etc ça peut être le
militantisme politique ça peut être
l'engagement citoyen à la mairie de
chantilly ça peut être plein de choses
il ya plein de voir et se sont peut-être
pas des voix du vivre ensemble c'est
plutôt des voix de l'agir ensemble en
fait c'est l'agir ensemble va vous
permettre de vous relier aux autres et
donc de vous sans de vous sentir en
cohérence avec d'autres qui partagent
les mêmes valeurs les mêmes projets et
ça va vous permettre aussi de vous
inscrire dans un projet qui signifiant
de manière absolue et pas uniquement à
vos yeux et qui
est qui sera signifiant auprès de toutes
les personnes qui partagent le même
projet que vous ce qui m'amène
tranquillement à la conclusion
conclusion qui qui sera fournie par
shakespeare pour shakespeare le sens de
la vie c'était pas de faire des enfants
même si shakespeare a eu trois enfants
pour shakespeare le sens de la vie et de
trouver votre don est le but de la vie
et de le partager merci
[Applaudissements]